يا اخويا كاي فتاه شابه تغني وترقص تحلم
وتنتظر ليس الموت طبعا
موتوا مهسا اميني على يد شرطه الاخلاق في
ايران كان بدايه نهايه الدوريات القمعيه
التي ارتكبت انتهاكات عديده بحق النساء
من شرقها الى غربها
وارتفعت شعارات غير مسبوقه رافضه من نظام
القمعي والانتهاكات ضد الشعب عموما
والنساء خصوصا
ومع الشعارات تنوعت اساليب الاحتجاج
اضرابات وحملات على وسائل التواصل
واعتصامات لم يوفر المحتجون وسيله لاسماع
صوتهم
كذلك تعددت اساليب القمع اعتقالات قتل
وتعذيب وتهديد ردود
جمهوريه المرشد انها ليست غريبه عن حراس
الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]
الناشطون والناشطات املوا ان تكون مهما
امي
لكن الانتفاضه حملت معها ايضا وجوه جديده
وشابه
نقاش كارني 16 عاما انتهت حياتها على يد
الحارس الثوري
[تصفيق]
لكن مقابل كل هراوه صرخه بشعارات كبيره
واحلى من اكبر لم يعد الامن مطلوبا بل سطر
المحتجون مذكره اعتقال بحق المرشد
والجمهوريه مع دخول الانتفاضه شهرها
الثالث
ودماء كثيره تراجعت الجمهوريه امام
الانتفاضه المدعي العام يحل شرطه
الاخلاقين لم يخرجوا عز لا امام الرصاص
لمجرد اسقاط شرطه الاخلاق
عمر العربيه